welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today and
if you want you can follow me across
social media twitter facebook and
instagram i'm at fahren
balanced i would appreciate any follows
you may throw my way but until then
let's get back to some more of the
biggest stories of this week and one of
the more grotesque things that we saw
happen this week in addition to marjory
taylor green's week-long meltdown
she took a minor break from that
to tell a british reporter
go back to your country
now we have the clip i'm going to show
you in just a minute but before i do let
me go ahead and set up the
you know set the stage for you if i
might
what happened here is that republicans
in the senate
worked with the democrats they came up
with their bipartisan gun control
legislation
long overdue decades overdue really
and finally we got it not quite as
strong as we needed it but hey we got
something
and sometimes you got to celebrate even
the smallest victories even if it's not
what you wanted you got to take the wins
when you can get them but marjorie
taylor green was angry
angry my friends angry
that those senate republicans dared to
join with those democrats
and take away your guns as she says
so she holds a press conference with a
couple of other uh weirdos
from congress including of course lauren
bobert thomas massey and andrew clyde
when she was confronted by a british
reporter and then this exchange took
place here it is and it's our job to
defend the second amendment yeah if i
understand that we don't have guns in
the uk that is true but we don't have
mass shootings either children aren't
scared to go you have mass stabbings
lady you have all kinds of murder and
you've got lost nothing at the
well you can go back to your country and
and worry about your no guns
we like ours here
go back to your country
you have mass stabbings lady
okay but
not
really
certainly not at the level that we see
mass shootings here in the united states
even before
we had the big string of mass shootings
taking place in america in may even
before that
statistics already showed us that we
were averaging here in this country 10
mass shootings per week
little more than one per day
and that of course is a mass shooting
defined as any single shooter event in
which four or more people are shot
more than one per day here in the united
states um
great britain is not suffering a mass
stabbing
every
day i i don't even know if they're
suffering a mass stabbing every
you know four months
as marjorie taylor green wants to make
it seem
the homicide rate here in the united
states is four times higher
than over in great britain
four times higher
and eighty percent of those homicides
guns
that's what's killing people eighty
percent of the time here in the united
states when some person kills another
one
guns
that's the difference
mass stabbings
are not something that people in the
united kingdom walk around terrified of
every single day
versus here in the united states you're
not safe in a grocery store our kids
aren't safe in school you're not safe in
a house of worship you're not safe at a
music festival
you're not safe at a mall
you're not safe walking down the street
you're not safe
plain and simple you're not
safe
here in the united states from gun
violence
it doesn't matter where you are where
you live red state blue state
yes some states do have higher rates of
course
but you go over to the uk
you don't see people cowering in fear
all the time
you don't see them out there saying the
only thing that stops a bad guy with a
knife is a good guy with a knife
they don't come up with those idiotic
talking points
but we do here in the united states
partly because we have elected officials
like marjorie taylor green
who rather than address the facts
rather than acknowledge
that this is a uniquely american
phenomenon because it is
she would rather insult that reporter
telling her go
back to your country
i mean we have seen obviously
these hardcore hate mongers
across the united states
i mean for centuries telling people go
back to your country
but here we have in the year 2022
an elected member of congress
telling another human being go back to
your country
are we even redeemable
as a society are we redeemable
as a country
if this is what we've got representing
us this is now the global face
of the united states and it really is
you know i i get emails i get comments i
get all kinds of things from people all
over the world
the talk about marjorie taylor green the
talk about lauren bobert or matt gates
or of course donald trump
the rest of the world does see these
things
and this is the face that we put forward
and i know this is just one individual
from a tiny little
county in georgia
who has somehow become the crazy global
face of what the united states is all
about and it all goes back to comments
like that telling a reporter
go back
to your country
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from fast
growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at real paper
dot com slash pacman the link is down
below